three two well well well
Friday who would have expected we'd be
here the day after Thanksgiving yet here
we are because we recorded this on
Wednesday but don't let that fool you
because today is a landmark episode of
the h3 podcast I guarantee this is
something that we will look back on for
years decades to come
maybe even millennium to come when we
get our brains beamed up to the cloud
we'll be looking back for thousands of
years now let me describe what we have
planned here today because this is not a
usual episode of the a street podcast
today as a special Thanksgiving themed
Zach can you slam the door as hard as
you can
oh it didn't even work yeah I tore the
door off the hinges in the last episode
I think you just tore the top one off
the door is just totally okay no worries
Brock the hinges here we're good today
is a Thanksgiving themed episode man
outdoors we put like a stopper like a
doorstop yeah maybe a stopper yeah I'll
work on it today
and what would it be at Thanksgiving
themed episode without the whole gang
here with us is of course Ella the
beautiful the gracious Eva Klein thank
you
who for clapping yes we're clapping
we're thankful to thank yeah absolutely
with us is Zach nomads well thank you
thank you very much
who was donned in a big lebowski shirt
Donny's last moments on this earth rest
in peace Donny with us we have Ian the
intern who despite his face is happy to
be here he's happy to thank you thank
you
and of course Dan the producer was there
he makes it all happen he fixes doors to
Gatsby's and everything in between
the reason that we've all and Sarah who
by the way is on the life switch does
she have a camera
life switcher she does okay it wouldn't
be possible without cero and we also
have our host thank you now guys oh
we've got an shredder and so why are we
all assembled here today well here we
have a pumpkin pie as is tradition but
beside it we have Cool Whip a
time-honored topping and yet another
giant jar of mayonnaise oh boy somehow
males becomes a tradition here on the HD
poxy I don't know how how did it may I
become the judicious but was it the
horsey sauce that started it
know what start yeah we watched the
world-record mayonnaise the woman eat
all those German oh and you thought you
could take yeah you made a valiant
effort yeah but that's so so began the
legend of mayonnaise well today we have
a special episode where we are playing
try not to laugh everybody's on Rue of
favorite genre videos on YouTube I
thought here's the deal each of us is
presenting a collection of videos
designed to make everybody else laugh
now at the end of the round I have a
tally I have five notepads for each of
you here so you keep a tally of who
failed and the loser everyone else gets
a delicious taste of pie with cool hwhip
the loser gets a taste of pie with a
huge thing of Mannix and guess what they
have to finish it or they're fired
something's got to be at stake hold your
feet to the fire Dan do we have a
sponsor oh yeah and today's episode is
sponsored by manscaped also proud and
happy to announce that it is Black
Friday and Teddy fresh is Black Friday
30 to 50 percent
off everything on the website did I
stutter yes from color blocks to new
releases to time old classics everything
30 to 50% off if you want at any fresh
now is the time you will never see
prices this low again the color block
has never been on sale before it's 30%
off it's outrageous
you better get over there quick before
while supplies last isn't that right II
though that's right a lot of plugging H
pastry shop as well we have a lot of
time to plug the a shoestring shop but
we'll talk more about that later
let's meanwhile just get into it dan the
wizard is attempting to fix the door
he's putting a he's putting a lens cap
underneath but it seems too thin what
about yeah it's not the Jeremy oh there
you go we shoved some used Kleenex under
this alright Dan have a seat I guess
I'll go first and some here I have 11
videos lined up and I have to tell you
guys I'm extraordinarily confident
mm-hmm okay the rule is going forward is
that you can smile you can stifle a
smile but the moment you like make a
noise you giggle you cackle you exhale
through the nose right what's the
verdict on a smirk no no like a no you
know no but if it was a silent but it's
okay you know if you're like smiling I
think ultimately the presenter needs to
be the one who who draws the there will
be a clear winners and losers here yeah
I think it somebody will merge who's
gonna be the weak link here I feel like
I'm in a laughable moment I need to like
wait I think Jax is gonna be the weak
link I was gonna say Zach - yeah I I
laugh at everything
so in Ian's a tough cookie Dan there's
so much at stake for Dan Dan's the only
one I usually I'm a hearty laughter as
the audience knows but but I'm gonna be
trying real hard
yeah so I don't know what's gonna happen
with damn button I mean guys it's gonna
be tough it's gonna be tough even for me
so well what if you laugh at your own
video yeah then they're not allowed and
I'm [ __ ]
oh you can laugh at your own video you
should definitely be able to so you can
kind of just goading everybody else into
it absolutely yes oh there's everyone I
agree
I can laugh at my own videos so you're
like in flats fun yeah I think that that
makes it way more
okay so Onishi on recently had we're
starting we're starting we're starting
I'm presenting you guys cannot laugh get
it out now
get it out next to me are you guys ready
so in tasting what we do is take a
classic right here I'm gonna invert the
spoon cover all 9000 tastebud area
warming up driving up that top go
I had a great band there vanilla smiling
I'm trying not there if I had never seen
this before I would definitely be
laughing Wow okay that's good I mean
there's a lot okay this one I feel
you're going to do a spoken word for us
now right right and tell us what we're
about to hear oh you're just a free
staff okay I'm just gonna pick it up is
there a style well let me sit back go
ahead Marshall okay
classics years ago they tried to exact
slap years ago they tried to
[Laughter]
laughs did you try to read something
from your book yeah yeah lost it I feel
like you left do you but like do what
does it say I think he just gets one
ding yeah there's no there's no scale
here well how many times I went Apple
laughs no one impervious it then it's
dealer slipper has the most dings at the
end is the one that only one yeah okay
you're right right so like since the
zach has more laughs I can laugh on the
next one and he'll still there's a lot
of rodeo save yeah okay okay gotcha is
that one ding for me that's one okay so
those you add an ins a couple okay okay
watch closely everyone watched ever do
right I'm sorry
let me do that again you guys watch this
oh no laughs mm-hmm account if it's
after the video yeah daddy's lap was the
thing I can't about watch it again
[Laughter]
because you already are you are you
laughing at my line wait what are you
doing though I was keeping an eye on you
he looked like he was had you had a
chuckle you had a chuckle very end
Zack's laughs got me you could get me in
here okay so you guys go okay so
everybody were full focus now okay what
really happened on that Thursday here at
Augusta high school that led to Chris
Wood's death
[ __ ] flying in my mouth [ __ ] I can't see
pilot and kid get the [ __ ] out this
country [ __ ] okay I'm doing it
again so you guys miss I love that led
to Chris Wood's death what are you doing
you can't look away
no you are looking away during the
funniest moment in the video look would
you watch that TV what really happened
on that Thursday here at Augusta high
school that led to Chris Wood's death
they don't know I feel like you just
exhale from your nose okay dance great I
love this video
and what's the laughing up to that one
Garrett did you guys know this video
yeah I didn't see no you going all
classics yeah yeah what's going on here
I told you I'm not okay
fresh died I'm here to come here to kill
watch
good evening I'm Ken Bastida Dana is off
tonight he was murdered and then set on
fire while celebrating his birthday one
more time this is like the best you ever
[Music]
seen Dana is off tonight
he was murdered and then set drying so
that real is that there was supposed to
be a comma between those two yeah he was
just reading the teleprompter and
they're kind of two-sentence man
together they're okay I just remembered
another one I'll show you guys oh come
on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what you that we all do with that huh
the pink ice cream looks pretty good the
Baskin Robbins
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like all this guy I've seen this guy
before I thought people posters and say
this was we got is this another ding
I got a ding everybody along this guy is
the ultimate there you go very good very
good
yeah remember him okay this is come on
this is a deep a 100 yeah there's no
other one like this particular one in
the world and you can see the tracks go
this way and it's really cool because it
records much more accurately nothing
I've seen that one a bunch I knew
exactly when it came even so I was able
to brace myself yeah also I think that I
think that's fake I don't think it's
fake I think the old man I don't think
there's an on it I could be wrong that
all guys know in that comments I think
he's just acting
'i'm office what's the current score
don't worry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you never seen it
why are you putting up cruller
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the determent is now lasted the trolls
[Applause]
see flashes from people taking pictures
of them
[Music]
can't do it proud even though most
popular super partner
it's just a spectacle it's just a
spectacle to you it's just funny because
the cops and they're always right right
you wanna go why don't you go [ __ ] off
with your camera and stuff stop Phil I'm
saying I'm not getting permission to
film you
closed no this actually a privately-held
really you're going to explain it to me
will tell me why they're closed
I don't know Cadillac favor you doesn't
want you in ok I gotta say oh man you're
annoying me
wait what's the score what is oh I need
to know worried about the score ok this
one I feel like is uh this one might
might I mean this I don't know you guys
[Music]
are you laughing you uh hey good really
you know he's into it oh this is a good
one and are you smiling
you're laughing yeah the joy that this
brings you is making me laugh this one
is just more confusing to me how does
this happen
he's at 14,000 views this is the deep
cuz I'm voting for 2010 this is one of
my all-time favorite video okay working
it doesn't views for the 2010 meme of
the decade he's gonna get him off he's
gonna get every last balloon
oh he's struggling on this one that's a
big one that's a big one oh that's a big
boy it's a finish yeah
[Music]
balloons old people popping balloons
finish oh he's he's a veteran he's been
popping those balloons since 47 yeah a
champ got more damn
whatever happened to totally crap bomb
I'm a popper - email chat with me here
on Yahoo I am whoo what is that I've
heard of that before I'm wondering what
the of the balloon popping yeah but I'm
wondering what the what's the pleasures
derive ish yeah yeah maybe the sound
especially there's one more but it's
really fast I want to make sure that
it's it's set up properly okay so when
you open it it plays everywhere on
YouTube actually I usually open it and
then I drag it really fast that time
stem to my stuff so I'm wondering you
base bar immediately deposit as soon as
it's open and
you can so it's closed I'm gonna tell
you there's someone who's losing right
now but it's very close mmm that connect
[Music]
so here we go interesting okay everybody
watch closely
nobody blink want to know the
behind-the-scenes video okay there's one
more wild card because we're actually in
a draw right now wow I'm not gonna say
but this one you guys let's watch it
three more times and you guys were tired
and you continue both
and we go do this and then we got to do
the Adria broman so why don't you guys
do that and I'll do that read beautiful
coup they set it up and get a nice
pumpkin pie with mayonnaise on it you
know there's somewhere somewhere that in
the United States that actually is into
that probably someone somewhere
yeah there's someone somewhere that's
super in the mail I'm pretty proud a lot
of election what do you guys think I'm
gonna go good what does it matter I was
purposely avoiding all these I've threw
in a couple all these but I tried to
find some fresh content I'm here
basically to introduce you guys to
manscaped which is the best products
even though you're not a man who needs
to escape who is the best and men's
below the belt grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels jingle balls to the walls
fellas untrimmed pubes are a thing of
the past
you've also trim your pubes sure hundred
percent you know when I was in college I
didn't trim my pubes because I never
thought about it but I think I turned a
lot of women off when they saw what was
going on down there yeah like I remember
one girl said even made a comment to me
she's like why you have a lot of pubic
hair
I swear got out yeah I was like I was
like yeah dude it's crazy but I never
shaved it like you needed manscaped
I thank you for bringing it back on the
manscape to him it's time to gear up and
get yourself the gift of shaving this
holiday season I am talking about the
manscaped perfect package too boy oh
I've tried to manscape using my tools
that I have and I have to tell you I
always cut my shaft and it's
traumatizing me too it's it's so
traumatic yeah now I'm afraid to get
that clothes clean that I want but the
rebbe but man escapes is changing all of
that because they're lawn mower 2.0 has
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology so that this trimmer won't
Nick or snag your nuts or your shaft
it's also waterproof so you
use it in the shower the lawnmower 2.0
comes inside there perfect package 2.0
which makes for the perfect gift this
holiday season it's literally everything
you need to keep trimmed cut free and
smelling nice down there well I don't
think any products gonna make me smell
nice down there regular chair and don't
use the same trimmer on your face as
you're using on your balls that's just
nasty I'm guilty of that I do it too but
I do it before I shower so I figured
what the oh yeah I mean listen because I
have my beard trimmer and that's what I
use down there you have two beard
trimmers are you a manscape I have
manscaped yeah hello we all need to get
manscaped ASAP
the manscaped perfect package 2.0 also
includes the crop preserver an anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
you already put deodorant on your
armpits so why the hell don't you put it
on the stinkiest part of your body yes
your ball sack the ball sack the
stinkies part of the body oh my god that
llegando [ __ ] gross with the
mayonnaise on Dan's
not good where was I stinky balls yes
stinky balls
speaking of sweaty and stinky balls I'm
thankful for the crop Reviver this
product along with the crop preserver
keeps your balls from sweating smelling
and sticking and these products smell
good they're manly scent is attractive
and it will help set up the mood if you
know what I mean mmm I recommend just
showering before I mean the perfect
package will also come with a pair of
manscaped boxer briefs that keeps your
junk feeling fresh all day it's time to
upgrade those overused pair boxers to
man escapes high-performance anti
chafing boxer briefs tis the season to
manscape so get yourself your dad your
brother your friend can you imagine hey
Dad I got you man scale what are you
trying to say cleanup - I guess it's a
good gift for everybody
your dad your brother your friend your
best gift of all it's manscaped perfect
package 2.0 so get 20% off plus free
shipping with code h3 at manscaped calm
your balls will thank you
20% off and free shipping with the code
h3 atman scaped comm that's 20% off with
the free shipping at manscaped comm use
code h3 clean up your nuts and make
Santa proud of you this year
alright h3h3 shop comm you guys know it
you love it it's limited time HD
podcasts merch all the proceeds are
being shared with all the cast members
here the Shalom everybody Elom over at
dan honestly into intern kawaii sally
salaried employees scuse me and Ian got
any Mayo Jack why do I always do that on
this specific shirt zakian made it is
why yeah Austin your head maybe you're
right I'm you're giving me the benefit
of the doubt it's the same manager for
the photo oh no ok good so this is a
nice and age okay yeah so head on over
there and Black Friday including the
color-block hoodie never before done
never done never will be done again
there's lost their mind okay we've all
got Cool Whip except like that no but
you have yeah that's we're good yeah
that's fine I got I got more than that I
mean what do you think a lot of cake
though could take some cake out of there
no that's so then Dan has never before
eating mayonnaise on the show gives it
mayonnaise phobia he's not doing well
but he's got to swallow it and he should
mmm-hmm
talk to me what are you guys feeling I
mean let's go
through your mind I'm not your over oh
this is good
with the mouse bow the first moment that
you taste in May or your brain is like
wait I reached that almost came up that
how are you feeling proud of yourself I
guess so are you gonna know we miss of
it yeah good I can't wait to win another
round how does it mesh with the pumpkin
flavor
yeah good only pumpkin pie oh I like to
actually like pumpkin pie but says Chris
might ruin it for me I'll switch you see
and II like hey Dan yeah here those felt
keep tally wash it down with some coffee
I'm gonna you take your disgusting
mayonnaise cake with you the smell in
here is pretty gnarly I feel like I'm
not even gonna laugh once with fun beans
okay I'm just gonna casually heat pump
wait what oh I'm just smelling the
mayonnaise oh yeah I panicked so I tried
to find new content but some of it does
some of it did end up being a classic
buckwheat there was no rule that said it
had to be new oh okay your job is to
make us laugh all right fair enough no
one's ready already
I'm ready no eating yams oh no heaven I
didn't recognize it interesting what is
this
you
all right that's it some mark Gormley
vibes right there I mean I was certainly
entertained okay that's something I'm
have a renewed motivation here not to
laugh after night so I'm gonna be a
tough sell from now on no more I'm gonna
worry about my list mmm then you pull up
the plunger and lock it in place on this
low match and let it sit for a while
they say wait about 10 minutes then you
take off the slow in Saturday but let
some air in then you push it back in
again
oh do you find it no I went old-school
dip into you three minutes for WoW seal
itself in pan you got the whole thing
off it's so simple
keep it going cuz I mean I lose track
don't don't lose hope because the
ultraviolet rays are what ultimately
cure the resin but I'm not a patient man
so UV like accurate much faster what is
he doing he's fixing a broken glass rack
in your windshield wait if they're big
like this one forget it because if they
start big like this one there's no hope
at all the crack will just grow
especially when you put the defroster on
when it's cold in the winter and the
heat gets to it it'll shatter like mad
in a product they can help ya
just don't expect miracles more quick
fixes on the Scottie Kilmer Channel
so if you never want to miss another one
of my new Chi repair videos remember to
ring that Bell
then slick you were close Dan I was a
little smirk over there to you I can
smirk
well that smirks or a lot but yeah I
mean you know don't feel bad I almost
laughed I did I mean it's a bummer
because I want to laugh terrible fate
actually if you don't make any of us
laugh I think you do can I claim
immunity from hello no that's round oh
that's lame so don't get insecure just
like he'll be confident and anyway it's
fine cuz you'll have a mouth you know if
you lose it's still fine because it's
insane you just gotta have a mouth I
have no problem if the look if the
presenter loses state I'm so screwed as
my pleasant side just go back don't push
me
it's fine restarting no pouting I'm
interested I like that what I'm so good
at gives me hope I break here yeah like
the Bligh's you're not into the pie I'm
assuming down no I'm good I'm good are
you know chewing look at your cute boys
in your house can you pass me the coin
what'd you put so little Cool Whip what
was that about
just a little dab a little dab will do
you you know not me little dad close -
they put in here dab on them you know
this is what I'm talking about
whoa that's yeah the bucket that's how
you use Cool Whip that's more kulit than
pie well wait but well yeah a lot of use
a lot of big whip oh is that real yeah
war it's like you drench it I've never
seen I mean it's just um whipped cream
oh can you show you a ratio first where
do I show it where should I show
that's a plate a clue right there yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome mmm what's going on
out there we are getting a package
delivered and I think this is
high-quality content I think it was time
sensitive what can we talk about to make
this more interesting we have a dead air
dead air oh we got shirts
let's wait till the next presenter down
oh my god it'll cool wet hmm okay
ready my bad side is as bad as my
pleasant side is pleasant all right
thank you I like to keep things informal
in here as much as possible but where
the difference between informal and in
Politis and I won't tolerate in polite
if I hear one more of these overly loud
yawns what you're outside what class
whatever it is you need to do to get
over it
I want to know why two hundred and
twenty other people in this room don't
find the need to do that
and you should be it's probably like an
8 a.m. class guys hating on someone
yawning don't push me to this point
again that guy beats his wife cuz you
don't push me to this point again like
they're bolts to anonymously tell me who
it is
whoa did you end it anyone wasn't
anonymously tell me who that was yeah
Dan the part that got me it made it
should have made you all laugh
was and watch him cuz he's smiling as he
goes my pleasant side that's right as
pleasant as my mean side is is as mean
I'm its party line and Marsha okay
[Music]
you're confirming our us being soul
mates because I timestamp that and when
you pointed it out and I appreciate it
because this room is cold I'm it's a
tough crowd and I'll tell you what us I
I'm riding for you to as my pleasant
side is Pleasant you want to let it we
didn't have this blade above my neck I
would have been just guillotine yeah
problem played again EULA we got a lot
more to go through all right once the
Ethan double back and reinforced that
moment it did give because I'm hoping
I'm you know I'm riding for you either
yeah so only me and Ian are on the board
right now like the guys never squirrely
your [ __ ] that's a good that's when
it's gonna play it again though and just
look down
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know I'm so confident I finished my
pie oh this is this is one of the best
when I'm not looking for is some big oh
come on okay I just know somebody in
this video I don't know when I'm not
looking for is some big overgrown
monster so wait do it again just stare
him you do I did laughs did you laughs
you know do you know in this video then
go ahead ela Sara and I both know he was
excuse me
Zak look at Zak go ahead just look at
these was it cool bad people back then
no I mean that was just like so uncalled
some big overgrown monster that's always
thinking about food he's describing me
do you understand that
all right they're over it
let's keep moving yeah I gotta make oh
man I hear up there is getting closer
maybe I don't know everyone watch good
I gotta get cereal you can't you cuz
that's high I'm getting serious I'll go
okay I'm done I'm done
let's see the Statue of Liberty from
here I can't stand it when she touches
me people say that time heals all wounds
[ __ ] play it again and just look at
him though he wants the lava so does
Ethan I'm good you're in first the one
do you watch the TV that's Ian goth me
and the water is warm or just woman what
what is the point of this video yeah I'm
not sure what they were shooting for but
they're always the same thing
it's like act a shoe my name is Carla so
you can stop at five or six stores or
just one oh I don't need friends yeah
maybe I just never got that deep into
the video you could stop at five or six
stores or just run yeah I feel like
there's an audition the headlights of
love
honey you smirking a little bit ears on
the board there I go just you could stop
at five or six stores or there's a
little smirk action going on over there
you could stop at five or six stories
good or just one Oh Dan laughs are you
trying to find like stuff that you guys
haven't seen before the whole video got
everybody even serious the beginning
I've seen I get this off the screen
before I left this is like some
connection there you go I feel like I
just saved myself maybe okay so we have
one more is it a tie there's three
people here at i/o Wow I think like you
know in there no I think it's Ian
oh maybe okay hold it is there hold it
together so now I wonder if I should
show the whole oh yeah this one is the
whole let it breathe deal and for an
attack where you see weakness John I
want a divorce in this one to divorce
it's a magnet it's not Connie John and
you know what's been coming for a long
time well divorce why do you always
laugh when I'm upset Oh every time you
say divorce she just looks so cute
I'm serious is time John serious I'm
absolutely serious when you're treating
this like some kind of game
I'm tired of it John we love games
not anymore not your kind of games your
games are cruel
divorce stop laughing this is not funny
things haven't been working out for a
long time and every time I try to talk
to you about them you laugh tomorrow
I'll drop the papers and that will be it
we can go our separate ways no no no no
no it's just not it's just not well you
know I don't know six minutes I think we
passed the question is we hiding like a
poet I yam was the closest I didn't let
I didn't laugh in life in the rules
is there a wild card possible even break
that who's tied there's a question am I
one of the ones it's time because I
think you be it Ian well that's it's a
problem cuz I got to go run get that
thing from outside right now went to
another school Canada
alright so do you so is it me Danone in
yeah yeah I like it yeah do this do you
want us all to eat a slice or xerath we
did last time you did last time so Wow I
don't know if I can do another so soon
well you're just gonna have to puke then
you shouldn't a lot yeah you should have
held it down you can't you can't say no
I mean this is our Thanksgiving special
I'll do like the tiniest you did a big
ass but I did a huge dollop last
whiteman will have to yeah gotta do like
that and a small amount of cake though
no needs to be mad it needs to be mad
that can you
and you that or I'm not doing okay oh
yeah
just give me set me up a bite yeah you
want yeah I ate it all I'm a [ __ ]
monster so just car you could take money
yeah I'll just use Ella's here and
there's okay yeah I got me well you like
a slice of mail either would you like to
plug Teddy fresh black sail a back
Friday sale twenty thirty to fifty
percent off while we do this okay so is
going on right now and this is all
online but the way I imagine it in my
head is like everyone is like fighting
and there's like nobody's crazy going on
right now
yeah gremlins are fighting kids are
screaming it's a lot of oh that's a
healthy right no he's he's good he's
good yeah thirty thirty percent off does
that include the color-block hoodie and
all styles everything on the website you
said wow really yeah really
Wow i trample over someone for that hell
yeah I wouldn't literally cry I would
probably I would kill my cousins yes my
name yeah okay so I've got something
else your cuz I'm a good one Dan let's
see I mean Dan is taking like the
biggest bite of pumpkin pie ever didn't
ask the flavor
I mean it's cheers everybody a chance oh
this looks so [ __ ] gross oh oh oh
hmm that is so bad they're so wrong
especially like my night was like 50/50
Oh
uh-huh oh my god that's so wrong just my
water rats that time like I didn't
almost throw up look again Durham but
it's still that was still really yeah
well your fight first bite was I might
um next yep how do I keep ending up here
with this man he's in my bro that was so
wrong yeah yeah don't like that not a
fan I feel like the rule needs to be
it's a 50-50 buy okay
fifty oh come on well you've got
immunity well yeah yeah you only have
two more rounds to survive wait here we
wanna did you have to go grab something
no no he's good okay I wonder if we want
to do it was literally there was legit
if what arrived weld in something oh we
can real get we're good well okay is
this the best or worst show of they
should certainly a Thanksgiving special
it's a special one I mean this beautiful
piece has been ruined by my eat it off
that was so [ __ ] gross this is
without a doubt the worst episode of the
issue a podcast for the audio listeners
is exclusively watching videos that they
can that's funny because last time when
I try to did not show video and just
describe was that because I can't show
fights yeah the video listeners lost
their mother
I'm like well audio listeners deal with
this all the time yeah and then the
video listeners lost their damn minds
well I mean I will include all these
videos in the episode description I
don't that's a lot of clicking on links
just go to youtube one yeah just just
just watch it okay so yeah I mean
similar to ela I pulled I mean I have a
lot less like long ones meant a lot more
and I got a hold it down this time yeah
I feel queasy yeah yeah that was just
awful I mean everything was wrong about
that tell me what you guys think about
this guys inspirational speech for this
football game
[Music]
you is that when you when you eat a
double you yeah they lost by like 20
points so if there's one more time
so he's hyping up his team is just get
him ready for the bad context is it for
yeah
they lost it's a bad hype cuz it's like
eat I might I was like yeah I want to
win I don't necessarily want to eat a W
right I'm gonna see it on everybody's
faces they're not uh they're not yelling
it but all right well you know up crowd
tough crowd
I don't know that one the other day damn
[Music]
good physical comedy right here oh man I
guess
EAL Allah he's got it it should get the
same on it
back now look at the TV you can't look
away did I feel like you looking away
from the TV one more time I feel like
that's a violation just real quick just
and and just look I mean it's a kid just
got slammed in the head of the lid yeah
are you not seeing this [ __ ] Zack you're
covering your mouth you look going away
I didn't hear the laugh but the NASA D
are you doing where's he taking that
thing anyway stay there okay though
everyone but Ian left yeah that's some
[ __ ] yeah sorry that's the game he's
good that's the game this one's a
classic amnon Suzy everyone's probably
seen this one he uh uh that was a really
good one though damn yeah
I'm not losing you understand this is
from a classic tone are you show me
those before
[Music]
I'm just like thinking of my mom dying
or something while she hit just once
more
yeah watch this closely this guy was
actually nominated for an award right
[Music]
here look closely this is the bar steady
one for the old it together together no
latching it's close
damn alright moving on are you good
though that's a classic that's a classic
let's see what movies up fro it says a
description I forget called Silent Night
deadly night part 2 part 1 many people
say the sequels are rarely best but
shows an exception here we go this is
just this is just a quickie this is just
a quickie
[Laughter]
but through a lot of effort just imagine
you first understand what I was seeing
take it everybody lost and that means
I'm probably still come on Ethan pull
together you think of this Nic Cage
[Music]
famous right yes before the tax fraud
look it's wrong
[Music]
I love the dollar bill out what a big
and they don't leave the state either
love what kind of like I gotta I want to
see Wow who would have ever expected
that that guy would have been like fifty
million dollars in debt he just didn't
pay taxes and spend all his money and
now he's like dead broke it does a bunch
of shitty movies actor of all time he is
a very good actor yeah like the crazier
you are the better the Act I mean like I
like Tom Cruise you know I like Mel
Gibson as actor used to be my favorite
just so happens that he's in he won't
you know doesn't like Jews or black
people yeah I think it's just the Jews
right know something's not down with it
he got he was doing that drunk he he
said to his ex-wife drunk on the phone
it's one of the best things ever he says
I hope you get raped by a packet n-words
whoa and record it on a record at home
wait wasn't that his girlfriend did he
have a kid with her yeah and she who
used to go on these drunken rants and
call her name and he said that to her
and she recorded it isn't the best I
still play that on Howard all the time
crazy oh this looks promising
yeah this is gonna be tough I could tell
bit up so the long or the the
accelerator is gonna be hard is the same
fun taking Florida backwards and it kind
of gets in a runaway
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's kind of like a runaway chain
reaction something wrong with in the
momentum of him jerking forward is
setting it into reverse
other directions a three-way tie is it
me I remember I passed one I don't think
it's me hmm I think I it's not me we've
watched a lot though I'm holding it down
I'm not eating mayonnaise this time
Dan's gonna eat mayonnaise we got here
contagious laughter that's cheating Dan
that's brilliance is what that is don't
say so myself speaking of which another
one by the way the ones that I chose
works great for my brain no subreddits
just saying I went a good amount of
those words like that lawn mower one I
had found a long time ago and I went
seeking that out but then that led me to
find this one okay which was on the same
cell friend
but I just can't stop myself at this
point
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
impossible not to laugh was that the
girl that the dating dude was talking
about dating dude was talking about oh
come on my 600-pound life was that show
everyone that face she made was amazing
this one I gotta come on Ethan hold it
together dude okay come this one I don't
know you may tell me I have to take this
one out why I'm into it pony fetish I
mean we had talked about it there was
like an h3 video about this before right
I mean it doesn't show like yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what they call Pony space and I put the
gear on that actually turn into horses
when I think the baby his mouth it's
like a ritual between us and I can feel
through the [ __ ] when he actually kind
of changes from the human space to like
pony space space he came out in for the
reigning competition for us during play
if I just put him in the gear and then
we go immediately do it it doesn't give
him time to transition I was the first
to laugh yeah well you [ __ ] me up
because you keep playing
the other cordis sir
yeah a lot to take in here people are
proud of him they can I'm sure it's a
lot of craftsmanship gone these people
find each other it's also very to the
Internet this is the downside of the
user so interesting taxpaying citizens
Monday through Friday so to get to the
weekend it looks to disturb I'm keeping
it yeah I'm not horsing around on this
one
[Laughter]
you look like Milton from office space
[Music]
with my stapler yeah might like this one
just cuz you're a fan of his dude I got
a keeper together Ethan this is not a
good showing
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
very good
the motorcycle let's slow down one
especially the second set of motorcycle
it's really yummy yeah yeah I thought I
would get him but I guess spoil together
you got more I think I have one or two
more here I'm on do not even one of the
my credibility's on the launch I get
this ready that Mayo is coming your way
I think I'm sure I mean well I'm
definitely either in 2nd or 1st that's
for sure
let's see no I think I've survived one
round only dad knows only God does
mm-hmm
zach has it had any yet you've been
holding done
you never had any mail no wow Ian hey
even had mail yeah thank God so um
what's going on over there that's gonna
be tough I'm just making sure I don't
spoil it by it yeah okay
Ethan this is your moment we are not
losing we are not eating mayonnaise
again come on come on hold it together
[Music]
bought the wrong firewood
[Laughter]
now I only show this one cuz I made sure
to research it no one was hurt seriously
hurt who cares it's hilarious well cuz
there's kids I know I don't want anybody
to be illegal that's [ __ ] the kids guys
you can just show it again and you exact
yo why oh my gosh let's go look how
excited they are I can't laugh it
because I may have seen it the other day
alright well everyone else left Wow okay
[Music]
I think I have one like one last one I
need if I win if I don't laugh with Tony
this is a classic I have a feeling you
guys have probably seen this
[Music]
come on Ethan unfortunately it got it's
weird it got deleted off YouTube just
the other day and it had been on YouTube
for it was posted in like 2012 or
something like that oh it's not Scarlett
Johansson from that's definitely not
yeah it's from that what's it called
ghost in the shell' movie okay screen it
first and then let's do that
trying to get it you know it's close
enough they go to it
this was from a Paula Deen and Oprah
special I don't wanna see that okay yeah
he does know what he remembers the mayo
made us laugh no I don't know he did not
laugh so we ever gave a smile and it's
between our wonderful to co-host
why couldn't I just know I was I hate
saying this but I really gotta pee so
you say that on the day I can't hit this
I know no we got to do the mayo and
here's another thing is the time you
guys have to probably go soon quick so
can we do like a power round I mean if
one I want to have well then I can fire
off one cuz I don't have that many
I'll give breathin first of all well in
goes if nobody laughs you eat okay well
and then you guys wrap your mail let's
go
and by the way do we mention teddy fresh
cop Black Friday sale 3050 percent on
putting the color-block hoodie right now
only a teddy fresh car bloody and
everything you buff in stock everything
gets blur so it must go it's probably
going already we got what color but what
if 50% didn't present hey fish calm so
actually a leads from that cuz that's
mine yeah
you said equal parts male well you don't
you you said that not me okay so you
will you lose you'll need equal parts no
good I said alright I do whatever you
want do whatever you know I'm going
equal parts that's not equal parts
that's what you dude bro now you're
gonna say okay is that not equal parts
but it's deceptive optical illusion it's
not mayonnaise that's a lot of [ __ ]
man that's all anybody much pie right
now yep no it's not look at all that
mayonnaise bro it's like mixed up to
what do you know you don't even laughs
all right hit it
do you have yours yet I'm gonna eat from
that Oh got it this is Oh God oh god
it's so wrong I don't like it no go I
need my water too why am I losing big ol
spoonful all right yeah power round
right
what happens if erm not bad oh she says
she will stay a little later you'll
remember a little later now now Ian told
us this morning I have nothing and
though he knew for weeks he was supposed
to be looking out you can do any look
I'm just saying what Wilde said why are
you the only one they can't find
something funny I don't laugh a lot
that sounds really sad but I don't ok if
this isn't funny you're eating okay okay
alright go ahead
how's that going down for you oh [ __ ]
oh no yeah it's bad isn't it it's bad
we're doing
go ahead this is Soulja Boy on twitch
all of his people were telling him to
please turn the volume down and he
refused because now I'm breath you know
[ __ ] burn I don't care if the music loud
and they get I'm not the I'm not your
daddy [ __ ] trying to speakers now [ __ ]
[ __ ] y'all stop complaining like some
hoes is here all night doing camera
shaking in this does this thing where he
hits smelling salts do you want hit
smelling salts on the camera what do you
you were just what helping you wake up
to stay stay fresh well cuz you said if
you guys have any props already oh these
are the shirts by the way as that get
set up
where's look great
so everybody show off your shirt h3h3
shop calm limited-edition support your
crew support your nation Shalom
everybody in the salaried employee
kawaii Dan honestly the wizard Elon I'm
over it
Zak anyone got Mayo the Joker
h3 shoe shop comm limited time only will
be in time for the holiday seasons let's
go Zack let's get it okay so how many
can I show okay let me go to you what
time is it yeah you got like 10 minutes
I'd like to that air
[Music]
they're dead air this meme that I just
start off with that carving up that
white meat I think are you almost
laughing damn he wants the line I'm
offended frankly I don't I'm offended by
this
okay more like a okay haha that's done
okay
but you almost laugh no well you were
fine I think you should have to eat some
mayo for that one yeah well is he the
only one that hasn't eaten meal yeah
yeah
so am so here's the deal nobody laughs
male perfect let's go here is a video of
a digestive tract problems quickly
called manga Kazakh there's a miracle
for you no problems being delivered from
the no I didn't I wanted to but I
resisted I love that I didn't laugh okay
we've seen it was a great okay
it was a great I wish I was saw it okay
I've seen midgets grow up I delivered
from the colostomy bag here is a crazy
musician on a train always a good Jonah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
tough crowd
it was a good submission I just want
know that was a really good yeah we're
on there you are gonna eat that maybe
that was a very good submission I never
saw that no that was a new one
kiddo I smell
today's okay I want cool mark we're
going to make a Dan and Ian laughs mmm
shouts of European settlers still live
you hadn't played this for us every day
yeah you're gonna laughter you will
explain this every single day
persecuted for their faith at home the
Amish began coming to Pennsylvania in
the 1720s in search of religious freedom
they settled into a rustic way of life
here guided by a strict set of
traditions known as the ordinance or
order out smoking big joints and Amish
those images from Pluto were stunning
but now a new offer 100 million dollars
worth from one of the smartest men on
earth there are billions where
intelligent life might exist and now the
world's most famous scientist says it's
time to go find it wait I don't
understand necessarily what I was seeing
you're not familiar with young King Dave
young Dave or if he didn't go
did anyone laugh it was really hard not
to but but like I said thankfully you
had spoiled it by showing that video so
that guy who who are IPE has now passed
on was sort of an internet meme what
like five six years ago maybe four what
do you you song singer doing laughs on
the video anymore nice to try let's move
on we don't put too much time we're
gonna we're gonna have to do it young
king Dave deep dive I'm surprised it's
faster I'm interested that's rich rich
territory I'm definitely interested but
mostly I'm interested in watching Zaki
Manny's before we go yeah okay this
might be your last one yeah this is a
choose why we're die right now this is
all right Charlie Sacha Baron Cohen won
this award the one of the Charlie
Chaplin award
[Applause]
come on no one will happen I've seen
I've seen I've seen it many times
very good damn might be laughing we've
gone through okay give us one more this
just set is getting this is getting sad
that way we said that was the last one
it was a good submission no there's lots
of good submissions I'm just really want
to see you eat thank me it's find one
good one now cuz the tide has turned
against you dude we are holding firm I
just saw Sacha Baron Cohen pushing old
lady offstage bro that's classic though
okay one more chance here while the sack
serves you up a big dollop okay in light
of big dollop big dollop you scoop huge
and late in the mayonnaise I'm about to
eat why is that
Joey's world and man am i dude okay so
I'm kind of nervous
whoa the tails every thing that he came
up with so let's try this to see how
good it tastes okay here we go
this guy's something
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
for another he's gonna go for another
buyer down dude he likes it he's eating
it now
oh damn watch this because how could I
not Ajay world
well thank you for my yeah welcome now
you have good submissions I don't want
out there like ya know there was some
good stuff in there
you didn't I did we were trying in it's
like my band never laughs he's a
disappointment to everybody when when it
comes to this game not in real life
I got a good amount of points out of him
you gotta say that's true I feel like I
made you laugh the most yeah me me laugh
no yeah yeah alright Sam I eat enough
yeah yeah spend too much time within in
this office I know my god is this you
nice you are the mail came whoo yeah you
earned that shirt okay we got to wrap it
up we got a run happy thanks it's off
Friday happy Black Friday hope you had a
great Thanksgiving
I have no camera to look at you have
your Thanksgiving everybody I hope you
had a great the family time now spin all
of your money at Teddy fresh calm we
have a Black Friday sale 30% off there's
probably nothing left there at eight
straight a shoe shop calm all the
proceeds to shared amongst all the cast
members get your shirts in their limited
time they will be there in time for
Christmas for sure and they will never
come back ever again so hurry up and get
it to commemorate your favorite cast
members will have more time to promote
these as the week's come the sales will
stop probably in the early this first or
second week of December or something
like that I think they're supposed to
ship on December 16th so probably just a
week for that or something so we'll have
more time to promote these guys but you
definitely gonna want to pick up
probably five of every one of those once
you've spent all of your money at Teddy
fresh calm because this has just been a
did just been a huge plug basically but
I had a lot of fun we ate a lot of
mayonnaise we had a lot of laughs thank
you I am gonna sit here as it's
Thanksgiving I'm gonna say good thanks
and I'm gonna say grace form one
wonderful team here Zack the sound boy
from whom I mean mobility Mario's great
has been a part of our life and Zack has
came in on the sound board and it's I'm
actually
I got a fee so bad it was born from that
from the mind it's actually you know
what's funny is the first time Jack
played that we were kind of annoyed
because we're like like why would you do
that
yeah you got a customer but then but
then it turned it out that it was genius
and so the genius of Zack was born
Andy Andy actually does have to be so
bad I do and and of course Dan the
wizard honestly as it says they I I'm
looking forward to December and then
we're all taking a break I'm season
three is coming around right around the
corner so Wow here we go guys so thank
you all have a great holiday we will see
you and actually we're not missing any
episode
so we'll be back as usual but we're
having a long break hi guys thanks we'll
see I
[Music]
[Music]
you